and what a victory after a difficult
loss against Fabiano Carana in the
previous round you mentioned Legends and
Idols that you have in this game growing
up but today you defeated an actual
Legend of Chess leevon Ron and a living
legend such an incredible player tell us
your story how are you feeling right now
this is definitely the most accomplished
uh let's say player that you've defeated
in your
career yeah it feels amazing to beat
leavon he's he's simply a legend as
puted I've been following his games ever
since I've grown up other than that
actually I'd like to mention one other
thing there's there's basically two ways
you can go from 2500 to 2700 one is you
play a lot of open tournaments and
another one is that you go you play
these you play these very difficult
events like us championship and so on
I'm the the decision I've been making
for the past like not just now for the
last like 5 years is that I'm playing
the tougher events so that for for
example my breaking of 2600 was quite
delayed I should have broken it by like
I should have broken it like 2 3 months
ago like this was a bit a bit too much
uh but okay this might sound a bit
overconfident but that's how it is other
than that like this decision I made for
example when I was trying to become the
youngest International master in the
world I played in all Grandmaster Norm
events and eventually that's what helped
me become Grandmaster quicker M because
otherwise if you get like I got all my
three Norms from grandmas events because
if you play if I got them all from I am
normal events then playing Grandmaster
normal events would be a different ball
game alog together but here I already
had experience on what to do and what
not to do and why are you saying the
same thing is this is the difficult path
compared to playing in open
tournaments yeah that's also a quite
interesting like open tourament they're
not necessarily easier that's it's
actually it's a completely different
skill set uh because the thing with open
tournaments is that actually nowadays 21
2200s are not 20 2122 HS they play much
better than that because every win you
get like two points and every draw you
lose like four it's a bit
ridiculous absolutely tell us about
today's game we have to talk about it
because it felt like a strategical
masterpiece yeah it felt uh this Kings
Indian I had the feeling that he was
going to play something like this
because okay he won yesterday and now
maybe he's coming he's trying to get
back into the tournament also I'm half a
point above him in the standing so maybe
if he wins this game he could kind of he
could kind of like Leap Frog me in the
standings and try to get second or okay
second or third or just a better ranking
mhm mhm sure let's discuss it Knight to
e so I chose to play I I chose to play
D4 in this game in this tournament I've
mainly played E4 so I thought okay this
might be a bit of a surprise and of
course Lear play Kings Indian is like
it's very very known as such that okay
he loves to play Kings Indian right and
we got to uh this position how did you
you assess it how are you seeing your
chances right now were you encouraging a
fight in this game or you happy to see a
fight in this
one yeah definitely I wanted to have a
fight because to be honest in this
tournament he hasn't been playing his
best like the leevon that we all know is
usually having much having a much better
score than let's say what was it four or
five out of 10 he's usually on like he
like plus two plus three by this point
like I had a feeling that okay maybe he
could and try to catch him off off form
absolutely and yeah this was kind of I
think this decision with F4 was quite
good in the opening itself because the
issue is he wants to go E5 E4 and with
the PA on F4 I kind of take away the E5
square and although my Bishop on G2 is
uh is quite is a quite bad piece I can
always play Bishop one and I thought
like okay if the game is kind of closed
I can always I can always play like
Knight D4 Bishop E2 Etc and I should be
better the thing was actually he he was
playing quite quickly around here I was
a bit confused because actually once he
played the C5 move I kind of realized
that if black ever gets a Pawn on C5 if
like if I didn't get C5 in the game if
black puts a Pawn on C5 I have the issue
is like okay white is kind of has no
space and and it becomes quite difficult
to make moves with white so I decided
that okay I should go C5 and it's kind
of like a double-edged sword because
from one point of view I kind of ruined
his spawn structure but from the other
point of view I give him the D5 Square
where he can activate his knights from
yep and that's exactly what did but you
got this nice kn6 move was
nice yeah this Knight B6 was quite quite
important because otherwise this Knight
these two knights are quite annoying
attacking E3 now after Knight B6 uh I
kind of force him to trade and now I
think H3 Knight F6 is kind of a big
mistake mhm mhm like after H3 he should
probably go C5 and maybe the position is
around I think white should still be a
bit better but but it's not too clear
like let's say h takes G4 C takes D4
Rook takes
D4 maybe bishop E6 or D5 and I can go G5
and it's maybe his King is still a bit
weak like maybe I go Queen D2 Rook D1
Bishop F1 Rook A4 Etc but it it wasn't
looking too clear like what happened to
the game is I had a knight on D4 like I
okay I put the Knight on A5 but uh this
end game has to be much better for white
like probably close to winning already
yep you because he just simply doesn't
have any play you assessed it correctly
and after that you conducted uh your
offense on the queen side very nicely
with A4 A5 blocking that weakness very
beautiful game to cap off an amazing
performance uh Abby Mani congratulations
guys any questions no our
congratulations too uh Mishra just just
great stuff it was your debut
um I I I just have to say you you must
be feeling great that you just didn't
you know face plan you know it's a big
big challenge playing in these national
championships they're so strong and you
performed well second place I mean come
on I actually do have a question Manu
congratulation on this tournament on you
know amazing score also amazing games
and my question is is this your best
tournament performance so far or how
much do you cherish this uh this results
in this
tournament I feel that this result is
quite good as I'm going to play in Grand
swis also another like five days and
that this will help me gain even more
it'll help me gain even more momentum in
that in that tournament because I think
as of now I gained like 20 25 points in
this tournament it's like a crazy number
I'm like 266 live rating and another
main thing is that I'm trying to hit 27
I want to become the youngest 2700
player in the world and I have another
13 months and my rating is currently
like 2616 and I have a feeling I have a
very good chance to break it wow wow
congratulations that's amazing I love
your goals uh Misha may you succeed
thank you absolutely and the aisle of
man tournament from